[music playing]
Well, we're gonna
[inaudible] the money, now!
I feel something good.
Uh-oh, it wouldn't go.
(SHOUTING) Oh, my god!
No [bleep]!
A damn car!
Who would've believed it?
What the [bleep]?
SHELBY: A damn car, man!
Shelby got a car!
SHELBY: Can you
believe that [bleep]??
You got your new car, Belinda.
Looking damn lost, man.
Ha-ho!
A damn, [bleep] bees!
I even got me a
bit on my eyeball.
MAN (VOICEOVER): Next thing I
know, he hits a wasps' nest.
10 to 15 bees sting me.
I'm running around
like a maniac.
Man, that [bleep] me up.
You got me excited now, man.
I can't believe we
done drove a damn jet
boat into a damn wasps' nest.
We get attacked and
get six stung eyes.
You know them bees we in now?
All I know is [inaudible]
stung straight in the eye.
Look at my head!
They stung me by six
or seven on my eyeball.
Or by my eyeball,
right above my eye.
It closed my eyeball up.
I couldn't see nothing.
Here we go!
SHELBY (VOICEOVER):
Yeah, me and [inaudible],,
we're going to see if we can
make a path so we can pull
this tree out of here, man.
WOMAN: I'm pretty
sure you can make it.
Just hold on.
Hold on.
WOMAN: Oh my god.
SHELBY: (SHOUTING) Oh no!
WOMAN: Oh sh-- (SHOUTING) Oh!
Oh!
Ah, [bleep].
Watch--
[dog barks]
Ow.
Here, come up and turn
this on [inaudible]..
You all right?
WOMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, I'm all right.
[bleep]
Ah, my legs hurt.
Where am I cut at, on my head?
Right here, look.
Might have damaged
my brain a little bit.
I don't know.
It's already damaged.
[grunting]
[engine starts]
WOMAN: Can you take
it easy this time?
- I think we got it.
- It's still moving.
Oh come on, Shelby.
WOMAN: What are you doing?
SHELBY: I bet
they're [inaudible]..
[inaudible], baby.
WOMAN: Oh my god.
Whoa!
Come on.
Seriously?
SHELBY: [laughs] We got
'em now, [inaudible]..
WOMAN: That's how you
get it done, right?
Just straight up danger.
SHELBY: That's how
we do it, baby.
Danger zone.
[inaudible] broke the boat,
but you got to [inaudible]..
This boat is made
for getting long.
[banging]
That's a damn
curly pine, ain't it?
Log to it.
Are you asking me?
Put that on the
bit back there.
It's outta here.
Always pass up the
good, man, by going
to the damn store and shopping.
Find it drifting.
That's some good [bleep], man.
I've been doing it since
I was little bitty.
This is gonna be
a mother [bleep]..
All right, come spit in this.
WOMAN: [spits]
Oh, my god.
It looks like you vomited
in the son of a bitch.
Son of a bitch, man!
You asked me to spit in it.
You didn't say how much.
Want me to do it again?
No, I don't want
you to do it no more.
Boys, did you see it?
God have mercy.
[inaudible] going down there.
Did you see what she did?
She vomited in the
son of a bitch.
How do you have that much spit?
[laughs]
[inaudible]
I want you to
rig the chains up.
Put the chain that
first [inaudible]..
You ready?
[engine starts]
SHELBY: Here we go!
Here we go!
[echoing]